well this morning about 1,500 Google
employees worldwide plan to walk out of
work to protest the company's handling
of sexual misconduct claims New York
Times investigation last week showed how
Google paid millions of dollars in exit
packages to Andy Rubin and other male
executives accused of misconduct the
time says Rubin who created the Android
mobile software was paid ninety million
dollars Reubens publicist said in a
statement quote mr. Rubin left Google on
his own accord in 2014 he did not engage
nor has ever been told of any misconduct
at Google or anywhere else New York
Times reporter Kate Benner was a
co-author of the story and joins us at
the table now Kate great to have you Eve
been talking about this story all week
I'm curious because Google's official
code of conduct on their website ends
with don't be evil and if you see
something that you think isn't right
speak up how does that play into this
decision for the walk out today sure I
think that a lot of people come to
Google because they are really
idealistic and they do believe in this
idea of the company standing for
something larger than just making money
and so to see this sort of behavior and
to see it condoned at the very highest
levels of the company I think has been
extraordinary upsetting for employees
and if you look at the 90 million dollar
payout to a single employee was
incredibly found who have sexually
assaulted somebody I think that's
calling for people this walkout is
already underway all over the world in
Germany and in Asia and there are
specific demands right that they want
what are they
that's correct so the employees are
saying it's it's enough is enough they
want more transparency they want the end
to forced arbitration especially in
cases of sexual harassment and so right
now the company does force employees to
be in arbitration which is a very
private process they want they want a
annual account accountability report
transparency around harassment because
they're looking at the fact that many
many executives have been fired for
sexual harassment and misconduct and
they had no idea so they would like that
as well they also want a global uniform
way to safely report sexual harassment
because that currently doesn't exist and
the court but he doesn't have that now
well Google executives certainly have
some explaining to do this is
embarrassing this is painful and clearly
mistakes were made what can you tell us
about how Google executives are handling
this
doesn't seem like they're running for
the hills on this no so it's really
interesting you know the CEO sundar he
has been extraordinary chef sundar
pichai he you know he responded very
strongly after the story came out Google
did not push back on us in many ways on
the story we we always do we run all
reports by the companies and give them
fair warning and in fact his statement
afterwards said we need to make a clean
break with the past maybe say he
supported people speaking out and he
supported the walkout today what's
important about that as by supporting
the walkout by coming out making those
statements he's also drawn a line in the
sand that the employees can look at and
hold them accountable to rather than not
speaking at all that's good we'll have a
women problem I mean 30 percent of their
workforce is comprised of women their
CFO Ruth Porat is obviously a woman as
well do they have internal issues
regarding diversity well I think that a
lot of the employees would say that they
do and even though they do have women in
high-level executive positions I don't
think that having a woman and a
high-level executive position means that
you don't have a problem with gender
discrimination can we go back to the
Andy Rubin issue because it's obviously
the one everybody pays so much attention
to how can his publicist say that he had
never been told of any misconduct is
there some words that are being monkeyed
with here or what you know I'm not an
attorney and I'm not Andy Reubens
attorney I can just say that we give
everybody a chance for fair comment and
they are allowed to say what they like
we stand by our reporting my colleague
died Wakabayashi who is an extraordinary
reporter was able to find documentation
other other you know bits of reporting
that we felt it was very strong do
employees have confidence in the
leadership do you think well I think
that's to be seen because there's the
walkout today and then there's the
response to the walkout will the will
the leadership comply with any of these
demands you know what another demand
isn't they want pay equity Google for a
long time has refused to release any
numbers about how men are paid versus
women they've come up with many excuses
why they won't do this so these are
really basic moves and I think that once
the deploys have made the demands if the
company doesn't respond I think some of
the good will that we see today will be
lost is there something specific about
Google and the way it's set up its board
it makes it difficult to make changes
absolutely and this is very typical of
Silicon Valley companies where they give
the founders complete control we've seen
it at
/ we've seen it we work which is a
release they're gay Brandon Larry Paso
Sergey Brin and Larry Page have complete
control so the board can't really remove
them and they can't do much to
discipline them so the employee pressure
becomes really important well it's an
important conversation to have and as
you said the CEO is really saying that
he hears all of this and he's supporting
this walk out today it's a first step
thank you